beth harmon's top five moves who is beth harmon
she is the star of the netflix show queen's gambit
make sure you go and take a look it's absolutely
brilliant now from one ginger to another we're
gonna go and take a look at those moves make sure
you like and subscribe to the channel this first
example is taken quite early on in the show where
she's playing should we say the kind of guy she
fancies who is towns this gentleman scholar of
a chess player and this is supposed to be taken
from the 1963 kentucky state championships
and here townes grabs the pawn rook takes
h6 a really bad move a very greedy move and that
move is punished how did beth now squeeze the rook
squeeze squeeze that rook until it had no squares
to go to first she plays king g7 that rook can
only move to h5 had the rook moved to h4 knight to
a free check forks the king and the rook leading
to a winning position so rook to h5 is now met
by king to g6 this shows the power of having a
knight in the center of the board the rook tries
to escape over to a5 where it looks like it may
be safe but i'll know those knights are tricky
little guys and knight to b3 picks up the rook
with a winning game world on beth you may be
on your way to greatness this second example
taken from her last round in the kentucky state
championships in the series this was based in 1963
and propelled her on her way to further success
the game is actually taken from the legendary
attacking player nets medinov and his encounter
against kasparian from riga 1955 well done to the
research of the show they've done a fantastic
job and in this position the game continued
with black checking but now after knight g6 the
fireworks start glowing like the color of her hair
rook to f7 in we go with a very powerful check
the king steps forwards can you calculate the
finish here queen takes g6 check the point of this
move is the remaining three pieces now combine in
a devastating attack normally three pieces is the
winning formula when attacking your enemies king
rook to f6 check rook to g5 and the checks keep on
coming and after this move is there any way to win
does beth want to draw she doesn't seem like the
kind of player who wants to draw rook h5 czech
king g7 rook g5 and after the king moves to h7
the final piece lands with checkmate bishop to f5
kentucky state champion here i am this next
example taken from one of my favorite scenes from
the whole series and in this scene she's playing
in mexico city three years later on in her career
she's playing a young russian prodigy who seems
like a very nice chap i have to say a lot of
the people in the series seem a lot nicer than
some chess players i've faced and here she seals
the winning move what is the move that beth now
sealed in this position which is very hard to win
an actual an improvement in a real life game which
was dmitry yakuvenko of russia very strong grand
master versus daniel stellwagon which occurred
in the wimbledon of chess wakanzi in 2007. pawn
to h5 this is the winning breakthrough beth's idea
is to get a pawn to g6 where she can support rook
h7 check mate now black's best continuation here
is something like rook to e2 and now a4 giving the
king the a3 square which it can sneak itself onto
after rook takes b2 check the king now perfectly
safe black's best defensive try is h takes g5
and after h takes g6 we see the point rook h7 is
what we call a rather juicy threat juicy black
has to try rook h2 but now the hoover can come
let's hover up those pawns boys g4 rook takes a7
and if g3 beth can simply swap off the rooks and
this position is easily winning because the a
and b pawn will storm down the board gaining a
queen the next puzzle that i'm gonna give you
guys is beth when she was sitting in benny's
apartment with a number of the strongest american
players at the time she was given this position
by those players in an attempt to maybe try to
trick her out or find how strong she actually
was it's white to play and win can you do a beth
and find the move that some of the players in the
scene struggle to find and do pause if you need
to of course beth just slides out the move king
d7 i am the queen of the chessboard and this is a
brilliant move which stuns the players around her
the point of this is that the knight is now going
to sneak its way around mainly to the e8 square
if black tries bishop g7 the knight comes to d6
next move it floats elegantly into e8 delivering
check mate if the king tries to run away knight
d6 is the winning move again if the king goes to
f8 here there's knight to e6 oh yeah nice
checkmate if the king steps back knight to
e8 again and the last move king to h6 i'll let
you guys discuss and solve in the comments below
now the last best sequence was her should we
say brilliant game at the end of the series
against the russian player borgoff it was held in
moscow in the series in 1968. the game is actually
based on a game of evan chucks against patrick
wolf where beth now improves on a van chuck's play
with knight to e6 a much more direct move
aiming straight for the black king the
game continued rook a4 a very critical game
to decide who is going to become champion
of this moscow tournament in the series borgoth
playing very aggressively but rook takes e4
beth continuing to march forward now gaining
a seriously strong e pawn that e pawn goes on
and around here in the series
they decide to adjudicate
in what is a critical and very dynamic position
the real critical moment though appears later on
when beth gets in with a check and after king h8
borgoth realizing what destiny might have for him
offers a draw draw beth thinks about decision a
draw would give her first equal but she proves
how brave she is by finding the winning idea can
you find her winning move in this position rook
is quite strong here anything to
do that no queen takes f6 oh yeah
the idea is to get the rook on f1 into
f8 borgoth starts to sweat a little bit
pawn takes f6 rook takes f6 and now one last
roll of the dice queen h5 hoping for some
perpetual beth keeps her call rook to f8 check e8
queen the queen queens and becomes the queen now
rookie two check again going for some per petrol
czech ideas king to f1 and best queen slides away
in very good manner with king b2 the king can't
be checked and bork off resigns like a gentleman
much more gentleman like than i've seen some
people resigning beth becomes the champion and if
you haven't seen it do go and watch it do go and
watch it i hope i haven't ruined it too much for
you you should have seen it already if you haven't
it's your own fault what can i say the queen's
gambit really is a pleasure to watch i'm assuming
you've watched it by now if you haven't go and
skive off work for a couple of days get netflix on
get your you know choc hot chocolate out sit there
and just enjoy it's got its up and downs but it is
really just a brilliant piece of artwork i'd say
and the acting is fantastic i love everything
about it and i really hope we're gonna see
stronger female players like beth appear in the
chess scene in the future do like and subscribe
to this channel and hopefully we'll be back
with more beth like action in the future